[Música]
la pregunta del millón y ustedes qué van
a hacer de su vida
a mis ocho años yo se las puede
contestar
voy a hacer astronauta
tenía preguntas muy ridículas
cómo sería pisar la superficie de venus
se puede respirar en marte la cosa nunca
fue por ahí en venus por ejemplo hay
actividad eléctrica de 25 relámpagos por
segundo
creo que cualquiera de nosotros que
pisamos ese planeta que haríamos como
pollo frito
pero toda una ciudad la curiosidad y la
ciencia nace de la curiosidad
en nuestra época somos muy afortunados
porque nos toca vivir un cambio
un cambio de generaciones la llegada de
una nueva raza la raza cósmica
y es que la naturaleza ya no va a
repetir uno de estos ensayos parciales
no va a ser la raza de un solo color y
de rasgos particulares la que predomina
aquí lo que va a salir de todo este
esfuerzo es la raza definitiva
la raza síntesis e integral que va a
estar hecha por la sangre de todos
nosotros de todos los pueblos
y por los genios y por esas razones va a
tener una mayor capacidad de fraternidad
y una visión realmente universal
en algún momento de mi vida recuerdo
haber visto una luz muy brillante en el
cielo
habrán pensado que era un extraterrestre
pero no
a la estación espacial internacional
y una estación que a propósito en este
momento tiene tres astronautas de
diferente nacionalidad abordando a una
velocidad de 28.000 kilómetros por hora
la aie se es como le conocen le da a la
tierra una vuelta en 90 minutos
y esta ha servido como una casa del
espacio desde el 2001
esta nueva cultura esta nueva era
espacial que estamos viviendo nos está
dando genes que nos inclinan hacia un
supuesto perfil de un hombre cósmico que
nos va a cambiar genéticamente para
poder explorar nuevos horizontes
yo siempre en mi vida tuve dos grandes
pasiones lo que es la aeroespacial y lo
médico
y me fue muy difícil poder inclinarme
por un sector
decide estudiar medicina y esta intriga
de conocer cuáles son los límites
humanos y su adaptación a medios
hostiles como lo es las grandes
profundidades el espacio exterior las
altas y las bajas temperaturas me llevó
a conocer un tema de investigación que
me ha acompañado durante toda mi vida
científica
fui ponente en el tercer congreso
mexicano de medicina espacial conocí
astronautas y dije eureka todo el mundo
tiene que conocer esto esto de mezclar
dos disciplinas para enfocarte en una
esto de saber cómo tu conocimiento
cualquiera que esté desempeñando se
puede aplicar al espacio
quiero que nos preguntemos algo y nos
respondamos a nosotros mismos
cuántas veces en toda mi vida
me he peleado con mi familia
ya pensaron unas cuantas veces en un
sábado en la noche he sentido esa
necesidad de hablarle a mis amigos a mi
novia a mi familia para hacer algo para
socializar incluso está la ex novia
les recuerdo que esta especie el humano
es una especie social requiere de los
demás
y es aquí cuando les afirmo que el
psicólogo viene a ser algo fundamental
para que podamos explorar el espacio en
viajes tripulados de larga duración
viene a ser la psicología aeroespacial
una rama que necesitamos en las ciencias
espaciales
el botiquín de los astronautas de
medicinas tiene antidepresivos
el ay ese es estación espacial
internacional tienen incluso la cama con
tirantes para amarrar a alguien por si
pasa algo
imagínense que lo selecciona para ir a
marte
cinco años de viaje aproximadamente
donde van a dejar a sus hijos
a su familia a su pareja
sumado con el riesgo de que puedan morir
o que les queden enfermedades de por
vida
ustedes creen que es fácil esto claro
que no definitivamente no y es aquí
donde los psicólogos nos tienen que
ayudar para poder responder a las
adversidades
conocí una persona con muchísima
trayectoria en el sector aerospacial el
doctor melchor antuñano
él nos comentó en alguna ocasión que a
su oficina han llegado millonarios
apartar un boleto para un viaje espacial
por motivos de turismo y no son
astronautas que van a cumplir una misión
son civiles como tú o como yo que
quieren viajar al espacio
hay compañías que aceleran en un avión y
hacen una parábola en este momento de
parábola hay de 20 a 40 segundos de
microgravedad
esto ya está disponible en el mercado ya
lo puedo comprar yo
necesitan 100 mil pesos verdad pero ya
lo podemos apartar
el turismo espacial no viene a ser una
idea sino una realidad que estamos
viviendo
situación hipotética ustedes son
multimillonarios y les gusta mucho el
espacio crean su compañía espacial como
lo han estado haciendo los millonarios
últimamente
tienen permiso para lanzar satélites
para lanzar cohetes
se la van a pedir al municipio a dónde
pueden extra rocas de la luna
bueno es el momento donde van a
necesitar un abogado y no va a ser
cualquier abogado va a ser un abogado
que se especializa en derecho
aerospacial
la gravedad y la atmósfera terrestre nos
han acostumbrado a vivir aquí hemos
olvidado que por el planeta tierra es
porque vivimos
lo que nos enseñan en la escuela de
medicina es el humano aquí en la tierra
no fuera de ella
al salir de la tierra cambia totalmente
empieza la adaptación del hombre al
espacio
dolores de cabeza dolores de columna
pérdida de la visión probabilidad de
cáncer degeneración neuronal
osteoporosis pérdida de masa muscular y
ahí le paramos porque son muchísimas
viene a ser entonces el ejercicio que
ellos hacen a bordo de la estación
espacial algo esencial para que ellos
puedan cuidar sus músculos y sus huesos
y no solo el ejercicio lo que ellos
comen la dieta
nutre sus huesos y sus músculos y es
aquí cuando les digo que los médicos no
somos todos necesitamos un equipo
multidisciplinario en la exploración
espacial que nos diga qué es lo que van
a comer cuál va a ser la rutina cuál va
a ser la rehabilitación después del
vuelo como los vamos a entrenar antes de
llevarlos al espacio
conocí un joven en guadalajara en uno de
estos eventos del espacio que tenemos él
es artista y se convirtió en un gran
amigo mío y él dijo claramente yo soy
artista y quiero participar en el
espacio
muchos se rieron dijeron cómo es que un
artista va a pintar en el espacio
él creó un estilo de arte llamado 100
sismo
su estilo es combinar el arte y la
ciencia para poder inspirarlos a todos
ustedes
para que se pregunten qué es eso bueno
pues esto es una sandía abstracta basada
en la deformación del espacio-tiempo en
la relatividad
y el su estilo de arte es cuando te ven
de una obra te educa te explica la
teoría y te explica lo abstracto de su
obra de arte
no solo el mi padre quien es arquitecto
y lo admiro muchísimo
en una ocasión en un evento aquí que
tuvimos el espacio
descargo los planos de una estación
espacial china la tengo que por cierto
ya se cayó les puso medidas de escala
hizo una maqueta abstracta de colonias
en marte y los exhibimos durante el
evento
en aquella ocasión un estudiante de
arquitectura se acerca y nos dice
gracias
gracias porque no gracias porque yo todo
el tiempo toda mi vida me ha encantado
el espacio yo estudié arquitectura yo
nunca tuve la habilidad matemática para
poder trabajar en algo así y me acabo de
dar cuenta que mi conocimiento se puede
emprender en el espacio que puedo buscar
una oportunidad
en alguna compañía espacial gracias por
abrirme esa mente
y si el conocimiento en general es un
arma
te pagan por lo que sabes no por los
títulos que tienes no por las
calificaciones que saques
somos futuro
vamos a explorar el espacio y ahí es
cuando los invito a todos ustedes ya
todas las personas que nos están viendo
a que emprendan en el espacio
odontólogos necesitamos su ayuda los
astronautas también tienen dientes
psicólogos
denle terapia a las familias de los
astronautas seleccionen al mejor
astronauta al que pueda responder a
cualquier adversidad médicos creo que
está claro que necesitamos médicos
ingenieros sin ellos no habría nada de
esto ellos son los que construyen toda
la tecnología fisioterapeutas también
hay un programa de rehabilitación
después de que regresan del vuelo
nutriólogos díganos qué comer para
nutrir a los astronautas para que rindan
entrenadores entrene los antes durante y
después del vuelo economistas díganos
cuánto nos va a costar una misión a
marte es factible cómo reducir costos
abogados preserven el orden
legalicen todas las operaciones
aeroespaciales
artistas inspiren los
directores de cine inspiré nos para
poder soñar con las estrellas
cada día a más personas les gusta el
espacio
de verdad y prueba de esto es que aquí
en ciudad juárez
creamos una sociedad de estudiantes de
todas las carreras universitarias de
derecho de medicina de ingeniería de
todas las que ustedes se puedan imaginar
divulgamos educamos que es algo que nos
hace muchísima falta
investigamos en el sector aerospacial
la ciencia espacial
representa la última frontera en el
conocimiento y en la capacidad humana
nos va a tocar vivirlo claro que sí
quizás no toda la historia
pero si a través de nuestros hijos de
nuestros genes que van a contar como
nuestra generación lucho por abandonar
el planeta por preservar la especie
siempre los humanos nos hemos
caracterizado por algo
por superar lo imposible por hacer
conocido lo desconocido
y quizás hemos olvidado que esta ruta
hacia el hombre cósmico apenas ha
comenzado muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]